longtime general manager of my new york
jets and then he was a gm of the miami
dolphins and now he's one of the best in
the business talking about it on
television joining us here
as he's also founding the 33rd team a
football think tank consisting of former
nfl head coaches gm's and graduate
students he is mike tananbaum back here
on the rich housing show thanks for
joining me on such a busy day mike
hey roach great to be with you what a
day huh i know exactly what a day so
when do we let's just jump right into it
here when do we find out what's going on
in green bay because
roger's contract will inform a lot
when when do we get to see the fine
print or is it possible that they're
still hammering out
um whatever rogers uh the fine print to
tweet out to say that he's coming back
for year 18. what's going on there do
you think yeah
i think the deadline's 359 on wednesday
because at the start of the league year
so again just to reset for everybody
today and tomorrow you could have
agreement and principles and we're
seeing a lot of news come out but it's
really wednesday at four o'clock when
everything becomes official so for green
bay that's when you want to have the
maximum cap space so presumably you will
get a massive signing bonus you know
richard could be 60 70 somewhere in
their million dollars prorated over five
or six years to lower his cap number
that'll give them the ability to
hopefully get something done with
devonte adams on a longer term deal you
know we saw them get preston smith
signed and i'm sure they're going to try
to resign some of these other guys like
devondre campbell or rasul douglas so
lots of work to do for green bay but i
would think we would know by four
o'clock on one so then what do you think
what's the tea leaves uh knowing how you
know this works and what guru coons
might be going through right now what
what do you think of
is in fact happening with green bay and
rogers commitment to the team and they
to him right now michael i i think you
know if you look at the last four years
of drew brees's career in new orleans
they had the best record in the nfl and
basically what they did is they gave a
lot of massive signing bonuses pro rated
it out so they could lower the cap
numbers and if i'm buying boot accounts
to gm the packers that's exactly what
i'm doing i'm trying to get that cap
number as low as possible in 2022
i'm going to use that excess space rich
and i can go sign campbell douglas made
each other resigns to darius smith who i
had to cut but i need to know i'm sure
they already know even if some of the
finer details have to be worked out on
rogers deal i'm sure they already know
what the cap number is for this year so
they could kind of work around that
simultaneously and try to get some of
these other deals signed
and
how does it complicate things that their
star receiver who their star quarterback
is expecting to
be there and be happy to be there and he
wants happy to be there and no doubt is
trying to use whatever um
juice he has within the building to make
sure his star receiver is happy and made
happy is saying that he's unhappy with
the franchise tag and will not play on
it how does that complicate things mike
sure that that ties backwards to the
four o'clock on wednesday which is
they're gonna try to i'm sure get
something done if they can't by four
o'clock on wednesday the next big date
will be july 15th because that's when
you can get up until then a long-term
deal done on the franchise tax so i'm
gonna work really really hard with his
agent get in a room and try to get
something done by wednesday at four if i
can't then i'm just going to put it off
to the side understand that he wants a
long-term deal understand we want to
give him a long-term deal and i'm going
to do everything i can between free
agency the draft and then come back to
it's probably right after the july 4th
holiday so what what's what could change
between now and july like why can't
something get done now just because
there's too much else going on uh you
know what i'm saying like how yeah yeah
what what
what's the mechanics there
if i'm the player i may want to wait
because i want to see the market
so
i think it's a pretty easy deal to get
done candidly based on mike williams has
reported 20 million dollars a year in
charge you know he has to be above that
um but there may be a receiver or two
that goes even higher so if i'm devonte
arms i may just say hey just remember
this i'm not coming in on a one-year
deal and i could sign it on march
whatever 16th or july 14th but just make
sure you save enough cash and cap for me
and i'm sure he's telling his good
friend aaron rodgers the same thing so i
actually think in this situation rich
time is on dividend side that's his
leverage is what you're saying on that
front 100
yeah i want to see the entire market i
want to see every other deal get done
that's out there
and i want to take the best of of
everything and you know deandre hopkins
signed a deal that some will value at 27
million dollars a year but you know
there there's a lot to be to me there's
a lot to be learned by waiting if i'm
devonte harms knowing that aaron rodgers
more than anybody else will push to get
the best deal done for me
mike tannebaum here on the rich eisen
show mike um you and i are from new york
so i'm gonna just
give this next one in a very new york
manor um that might not be fitting of
the great um
state of minnesota but i will ask it on
behalf of vikings fans as if i'm you
know from new york what the hell are the
vikings doing mike tannenbaum
there has to be a belief that kevin
o'connell
feels like hey i could go win multiple
games with kirk cousins and basically
what you have to think about is like if
i set him to a one year extension
extension that gives me a couple of
drafts now to get my footing as a head
coach to draft his replacement i don't
think you can win with kirk cousins
especially in the nfc because you think
about stafford and kyle murray daf
prescott obviously rogers brady i mean
he's at best in my opinion six maybe
seventh best quarterback i think you're
just signing up for more mediocrity but
if you're a new head coach rich at least
maybe you're saying hey we're going to
get o'connell established
it's just got to be ti i just can't
imagine how a vikings fan and and i say
this with the ultimate of respect and i
know it sounds very disrespectful so i
feel like i've just
immunized myself from
[Music]
you know being critical but
that you just said he's the seventh best
quarterback in the nfc you can include
the afc as well then you're you're going
to go at least half the league
right this guy now gets a a
a pay raise
and has 55 million guaranteed by next
march
what does that say about the system
of our league then mike
yeah right it's just it's a supply and
demand with quarterbacks i mean mr biski
reportedly will be signing with
pittsburgh if mitch trubisky and james
winston was in this year's draft in my
opinion they'd be the first quarterback
taken so
kirk cousins to me is as you just said
rich when you throw in the afc somewhere
in the middle and that's what 35 million
dollars a year gets you it gets you
mediocrity um but i guess the inverse is
if you don't have him do you have any
hope whatsoever
is that his leverage that with
like a hostage taker like
you know what i'm saying like that
again this is a leveraged league you got
to have it or you don't how does he keep
having it by saying like the the
alternative is worse so you you need to
pay me like i'm garrett cole i mean it's
all guaranteed you know like it's it's
it's
right it's kind of crazy
it really is
i i think if you and i were running the
vikings the honest sober analysis is if
we let him leave right we're gonna be
looking at the mitch trubisky's marcus
mariotas of the world uh sam howell from
north carolina and and that group of
quarterbacks and
then you start thinking yourself like
well all right if we can get the defense
good enough and we got a great running
back in dalvin cook maybe we can you
know win 10 games and you know sneak a
playoff win and all of a sudden we're
sitting there in the top eight and um
that's what we're looking at because and
again that's why when we look at
trubisky or what's going on with sean
watson there's so much interest in these
quarterbacks because while rich there's
32 teams there just isn't 32
quarterbacks mike tannebaum here on the
rich eisen show so what do you make of
the trubisky signing
um in pittsburgh
what do you think
i think the verb there has to be scour i
think we lost all-time great in
rothersberger i think trubisky is maybe
the first step but
i've said this before if i was mike
tomlin and kevin colbert rich i'd have
the world's shortest scouting trip and
i'd walk across that pittsburgh practice
facility and i draft kenny pickett and
just because you have trubisky i keep
going because when you don't have one
you just got to keep adding one until
you find one so maybe
it's trubisky and kenny pickett and now
all of a sudden hey let's just keep
adding good young players and see which
one you know sticks but i think it also
says something a lot about they had no
faith in mason rudolph as well
so uh i don't mean to laugh but i just
did i'm sorry so um
that that you could say that again so
pickett's the best one or you just like
you just say him because he's there and
you covet what you see
um as opposed to malika willis i mean
how do you how do you suss out the
quarterback class coming in
because i i agree with you i said about
uh half an hour ago that trubisky
signing for two years means that the
steelers are absolutely going to use
their first round draft choice on a
quarterback unless they're all gone by
the 20th pick and they just you know
colbert just doesn't want to pull the
trigger and waste any more draft capital
on chasing somebody that he thinks isn't
worth a higher pick than 20th overall
yeah i think that's right like for me
pickett's the best quarterback um and i
don't think he's perfect but i think he
has a chance to be a matt ryan type best
case scenario he's a good athlete had a
really good year this year good arm he
did have 27 fumbles that does concern me
but he is the best quarterback in my
opinion um don't know if he'll be there
when they're picking they may have to
move up a little bit i think what
they're doing is they're hedging what
they're saying is like because of the
uncertainty of the quarterback position
where we're drafting at least you know
we feel like we've upgraded the position
with trubisky over
um basin rudolph mike tannenbaum here on
the rich eisenshire what's the 33rd team
mike what are you working on here
brother what do you have yeah i
appreciate you asking me it's a bunch of
head coaches and gm's that get together
and look at all the issues around the
league and some go back like dan quinn
and doug peterson and we put out
free content we have a free newsletter
3013.com and it's just a way to keep
everybody informed and uh get people's
opinions that have uh actually made the
decisions what if the league expands
will you change your the name of your
organization
i own the rights to the 33rd team so
they'll have to damn straight mike you
call you tell the nfl to back off man
you tell them that
okay so it's sort of like a think tank
or something like that because it
involves exactly graduate students too
how can people get involved in this how
can they yeah so you know our website we
have students that we've uh intern have
mentored with us and have gone to league
and got in internships with teams and we
take a lot of pride in placing a lot of
men and women uh in the nfl that have
interned with guys like doug peterson
and dan quinn and uh we're really proud
of that we're trying to help others get
to where they want to go what are the
jets gonna do mike what's going on what
do you think joe douglas is up to right
now they got a ton of cap space they got
a kid who they need to protect um they
got a you got a left tackle who appears
to be you know um
the top two draft choices at uh tackle
in this year's draft weight combined
because he's not uh healthy uh what what
what are they doing what do you think
the plan is here i think i have the jets
i think it's got to be offensive line
and corner i just
you know rich if you don't have answers
at those two positions you have no hope
and you know maybe you sign a carlton
davis and you draft another one like a
sauce gardener and now you look
dramatically better um it has to be a
complimentary approach like maybe you
draft a tackle sign a guard um and i
think you have to get a pass rusher
somehow some way
which this as we know this draft is
loaded from your alma mater you know
look they're not gonna get hutchinson
but abajo is really good you know
there's a number of really good pass
rushers so they got to come out of this
with with one and either free agency of
the draft so you think hutchinson's
first overall so what do you think yes i
100
when i saw cam robinson get franchise
that told me everything i need to know
i'd be shocked if hutchinson from uh
your university of michigan isn't the
first pick overall and then that makes
what uh that means detroit goes o line
could they go kyle robinson and just
kind of surprise people take a safety
that high what do you think
yeah they could i i think when it's all
said and done they they probably go evan
neal uh maybe it's a quantum from nc
state and now you have your book ends
with penae sewell and you know that's
sort of like the vision i would think
that um dan campbell would want in terms
of the vision of his team and now you
fortified you know you have two blue
chip
tackles and now whether it's jared goff
or somebody else
you have a foundation to build off all
right i'm sorry i i meant kyle hamilton
i don't know why i said kyle robinson
you just said so um so
i'm just trying to see if the jets have
a shot at trayvon walker what do you
think you think they do i think so i
think there's a reasonable chance he'll
be there and i like his versatility they
have to move him around he had a great
workout i don't know if he's just a
natural edge pass rusher but you know he
slid inside he to me has really good
interior pass rush which we know is so
important uh something you know
obviously the jets could use as well and
did kavon thibodeau hurt himself not
help himself how do you categorize it
with him not working out the combine
mike i i'd say this if he had not worked
out rich i would have been okay with
that but apparently he told more than
one team he was going to and then he
didn't and that's problematic um it's
not the end of the road by any stretch
i'm sure if he has a great workout as
pro day but that is something that um
would bother me if he if he
said one thing and for whatever reason
got out in the field and decided to wait
but he's a great talent he reminds me a
little bit of jason taylor his length
his get off he's a very natural pass
rusher wow that's a heck of a guidance
to to connect him with mike thanks for
the time greatly appreciate it good luck
with the 33rd team and look for my call
as we get ready for the draft thanks for
the call
sounds great really appreciate you
having me always that's mike tannenbaum
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here